bonjour bonjour Philippe Martinez merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin vous êtes secrétaire
général de la CGT merci d'être venu à
quelques heures de la journée de la
mobilisation qui aura lieu aujourd'hui
dans toute la France en étant sans
pendant 20 minutes en interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertrand du
groupe La Dépêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Oriane bonjour Philippe et
Philippe Martinez donc le jour J pour la
mobilisation que vous espérez forte vous
l'avez dit d'après les remontées que
vous avez à combien vous estimez le
nombre de personnes qui seront
mobilisées aujourd'hui dans le pays
c'est impossible de le dire
précisément vous savez que dans le privé
il y a pas besoin de préavis et donc les
salariés travailleurs travailleuses
peuvent se mettre en grève spontanément
donc n'arrivez pas à avoir une
fourchette après les remontées que vous
avez une indication par exemple en
Île-de-France il y a plus de 200 cartes
de manifestants qui vont converger vers
la place de la République c'était le
chiffre à hier midi donc vous voyez que
ça fait quelque chose de pas mal je vais
vous parler du privé juste avant parce
que j'offre en route des yeux le patron
du Medef dit qu'il ne voit pas de
mobilisation forte dans les entreprises
du secteur privé à ce stade elle va pas
faire la promotion des grèves et les
manifestations ou alors là qu'est-ce qui
se passerait quelque chose
mais vous pensez qu'il y aura une
mobilisation forte dans le secteur privé
vous savez il y a une ambiance et ça
sent quand les gens sont vous devez le
vous en rendre compte aussi quand vous
croisez des gens de la vraie vie qui
travaille et qui se disent je vais pas
pouvoir travailler jusqu'à 64 ans donc
il y a un mécontentement et on a
beaucoup d'appels dans nos permanences
etc pour nous dire est-ce que on peut
venir la manifestation quand est-ce que
c'est à quelle heure etc ça sent sur
route des yeux doit pas aller acheter
son pain tous les jours et donc il doit
pas être au courant de tout ça quels
sont les indicateurs qu'il va falloir
regarder aujourd'hui un nombre de
personnes dans les rues où le nombre de
personnes qui ne travaillent pas qui
sont en grève c'est quoi pour vous les
indicateurs le plus important les deux
parce que on sait bien que les
manifestations c'est c'est le reflet
médiatique de ce mécontentement mais il
arrive que certaines personnes
beaucoup d'ailleurs restent sont en
grève mais reste chez eux il y a des
problèmes de transport par exemple
aujourd'hui donc c'est les deux c'est
les deux indicateurs qui qui nous
montrent que ça sera une ça va être une
journée forte le gouvernement lui compte
sur une certaine apathie des Français
ils ont d'autres problèmes liés au
pouvoir d'achat à l'inflation et ils ont
pas la tête à faire grève ni à les
manifester qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
vous par rapport à ça
c'est bien que le gouvernement se rende
compte qu'il y a un problème de pouvoir
d'achat et notamment un problème de
salaire parce que il y a eu beau il y a
beaucoup de grève il y en a encore
aujourd'hui sur la question des salaires
et évidemment c'est bien que tout le
monde maintenant le disque quand on fait
grève on n'est pas payé et on a déjà des
problèmes de salaire avec un mois normal
perdre une demi-journée une journée ça
pèse mais vous l'entendez ça finalement
on fera pas grève parce que on
peut pas on l'entend mais
majoritairement les sondages l'indiquent
cette question des retraites elle
canalise un peu tous les mécontentement
que vous avez cités et bien d'autres
d'ailleurs il y a la question du pouvoir
d'achat du porte-monnaie qui peut être
un frein à la grève il y a aussi la
question du télétravail pour vous ça va
moins de rire l'impact de cette
mobilisation télétravail
c'est plus difficile évidemment de
contacter les collègues quand ils sont
pas sur les sur les postes de travail
même si ça touche pas tout le monde le
télétravail c'est aussi compliqué parce
que dans bon nombre dans une très grande
majorité d'entreprise les organisations
syndicales n'ont pas accès aux
messageries de l'entreprise pour
communiquer les revendications ça c'est
un vrai problème par exemple que le
droit social n'est pas évolué en
fonction des nouvelles organisations du
travail mais il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
salariés qui sont très motivés mais que
ce soit Philippe Martinez vous dirait la
mobilisation est réussie ou non le
nombre de manifestants et les premières
c'est un chiffre symbolique alors on
verra les polémiques habituels sur selon
la police et selon les organisations
syndicales mais c'est aussi un chiffre
symbolique et aussi c'est plus difficile
mais on les aura peut-être en fin de
soirée ou demain matin les pourcentages
de grévistes notamment les entreprises
privées et que vous que c'est quoi pour
vous à combien de pourcentages je vous
dirais ça ça a marché on a réussi on a
réussi notre journée
il y a trop d'entreprises
tout le monde le sait enfin tout vous le
savez aussi aujourd'hui ça va être une
très grosse journée de mobilisation de
surcroît quand tous les syndicats sont
d'accord ça aussi c'est un élément de
confiance pour le monde du travail et on
va y venir juste vous appeliez le
gouvernement à prendre ses
responsabilités pour assurer la sécurité
des manifestations dans le pays Gérald
Darmanin a annoncé le déploiement de
10000 policiers et gendarmes il a pris
ses responsabilités selon vous
c'est pas la première fois que je dis ça
je me répète mais c'est pas la première
fois que je dis ça et après j'ai pas je
sais pas on va voir comment ça se passe
mais nous dans les Cortés ça se passe
bien tout ce qui se passe de moins bien
c'est en dehors des comptes des cortèges
et donc vous en convenez c'est de la
responsabilité des préfets et donc de
leur patron mais la décision de Gérald
Darmanin de mettre 10000 policiers c'est
une bonne décision pour vous ça vous
rassure sur le risque de violence ou pas
vous pouvez comprendre que je ne suis
pas un spécialiste du maintien de
l'ordre merci
malgré bien que vous soyez pas
spécialiste
en Espagne aujourd'hui avec le président
de la République un jour de grosses
manifestations est-ce que vous trouvez
ça choquant je pense que
j'ai constaté qu'il a contrairement à un
ministre l'année dernière il est pas
Ibiza il est à Barcelone
c'est les choix du gouvernement il se
passe des choses en France
ils sont pas en France voilà
je pense que y compris le président de
la République de ce qui dit être à
l'écoute encore plus qu'avant il y a pas
beaucoup d'efforts à faire pour être
plus à l'écoute
devrait s'intéresser à ce qui se passe
et non pas considéré que bon il gère ses
petites affaires et que ce qui se passe
dans le pays interprétaient ce choix de
se déplacer pour vous c'est un choix
politique c'est un hasard de calendrier
je n'en sais rien je fais juste le
constat comme vous que quand il se passe
une très grosse mobilisation et qu'on
prétend écouter avoir changé et écouter
plus c'est le genre de journée ou c'est
le moment de rester c'est le moment de
c'est le moment d'écouter
on verra comment ça réagit sur des
coupures parce que vous savez qu'il y a
quelque chose qui a fait beaucoup
polémique c'est la menace de la CGT
énergie de faire des coupures de courant
pour les élus qui soutiennent le texte
est-ce que oui ou non il y aura des
coupures de courant pour ces élus je
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire mais je
vais je vais le redire que c'était une
symbolique de pour montrer le
mécontentement qui existe notamment dans
ses professions et j'insiste parce que
ils sont souvent traités par les
gouvernements par exemple de privilégier
mais en ce moment enfin où il y a une
tempête qui travaille jour et nuit dans
les conditions difficiles pour rétablir
le courant des usagers c'est eux donc la
notion de privilégier donc c'était plus
une symbolique que une véritable menace
comme je l'ai entendue et d'ailleurs je
crois que
mon collègue et mode camarade Sébastien
mes esplier c'est justifié et et vous
êtes patron de la CGT vous dites il n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas de
dire que papa vous maîtrisez pas la
branche énergie non non c'est le côté
vous dites ce matin nous ne couperons
pas le courant chez les études la
réforme je vous dis que c'est pas dans
nos habitudes de faire ça que c'était
pour exprimer fortement une colère par
contre je vous dis que et ça c'est
beaucoup moins dit que les salariés en
grève les agents dans l'énergie on
l'habitude de rétablir le courant c'est
ce qu'on appelle les opérations Robin
des Bois à tout et cela faut en parler à
tous ces citoyens français qui eux
n'utilisent pas leur courant parce
qu'ils ne peuvent plus payer leur
facture ça c'est une réalité est-ce que
les actions syndicales doivent rester
populaire ou est-ce que si le bras de
fer se durcit vous autoriseriez des
choses qui seraient un peu plus
impopulaire comme des coupures
d'électricité par exemple il y aura des
coupures d'électricité il y aura des
chutes quand les gens ne travaillent
plus
uniquement donc c'est un débat qui est
complètement absurde vous enfin voilà
quand il y a plus personne quand il y a
plus personne dans une entreprise il y a
pas de production et ben c'est la même
chose même si parce que ce sont des
travailleurs et travailleuses
responsables au service du public
évidemment ils ne font pas n'importe
quoi mais c'est à chaque fois pareil ils
ne font pas n'importe quoi
c'est mécanique parce que il y aura
moins de monde dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui ou est-ce que ça fera partie
des actions des crédisses de la CGT de
baisser la production d'électricité dans
le pays quand il n'y a plus moins de
monde qui travaillent ou plus personne
qui travaille forcément il y a des
conséquences sur la production après
la production baisse ça ne sera pas
partie
mais c'est pas une responsa c'est pas
une responsabilité ou un mode d'action
en tout cas des grévistes de la CGT je
crois qu'on se comprend pas bien ou
alors vous comprenez pas comment ça
marche dans une entreprise quand les
gens travaillent
dans des entreprises ou chez les
Français il y a pas personne qui
aura moins de production d'électricité
et comme ce sont des salariés très
responsables dont la mission est au
service des citoyens et ben évidemment
il privilégie
ce qui est bien public ce qui est
pour tout le monde donc évidemment et
tout tout c'est polémiques sont pour
détourner le débat de du fond de la
doivent craindre des coupures de
d'électricité chez les Français qui nous
regardent j'ai cru comprendre que très
mattejoritairement ils étaient contre ça
très forts que beaucoup d'entre eux vont
être en grève
des conséquences les conséquences des
mobilisations
chaque grève il y a des gènes pour les
usagers vous le savez les transports
aujourd'hui c'est avec c'est compliqué
voilà c'est ce que vous dites vos
capteurs c'est que les Français sont
prêts à supporter ces gènes parce que je
vous dis que je regarde comme vous les
sondages
qui sont très majoritairement contre
cette réforme c'est ça le fondu c'est ça
la question et que majoritairement ils
comprennent et ils soutiennent la
journée d'action on a entendu un grand
nombre de ministres cette semaine dire
d'accord pour manifester non pour
bloquer le pays c'est irresponsable
est-ce que vous sentez lisez est-ce que
vous écoutez serait de bloquer le pays
pour retirer pour pousser au retraites
et c'est le gouvernement essaye de
détourner l'attention et de faire peur
et moi je ne tomberai pas dans ce piège
là quand il y a grève il ferait mieux de
s'intéresser
aux questionnements des citoyens qui
vont faire grève aujourd'hui quand il y
a grève il y a des gènes et je conteste
l'idée de blocage quand il y a oui quand
il y a grève et ben il y a des problèmes
mais tout le monde le sait et ça fait et
c'est pas nouveau depuis que le droit de
grève existe c'est comme ça et il y a et
voilà c'est tout et donc par contre je
je pense que comme ils sont très gênés
pour expliquer leur réforme et bien ils
préfèrent parler d'autre chose et
parlons de la réforme
il a appelé à faire le distinguant entre
les syndicats qui appellent la
manifester dans un cas de traditionnel
et républicains et ceux qui sont dans
une démarche délibérée de bloquer le
pays voir cibler des parlementaires vous
êtes sentis visé par ses propos je crois
que Emmanuel Macron n'est vraiment pas
un spécialiste du syndicalisme et
d'ailleurs elle le démonte depuis qu'il
est président donc c'est c'est
commentaire sur le syndicalisme je
préfère moi je suis plus spécialiste que
lui pour parler de syndicalisme ouais
pour la première fois les syndicats sont
unis depuis 12 ans vous allez défiler
côte à côte aujourd'hui derrière la même
banderole est-ce que on aurait donné
est-ce que cette union peut durer
puisque le gouvernement va essayer
évidemment essayer de vous diviser
est-ce que dans vos discussions avec
notamment la CFDT vous vous sentez
quelque chose de durable vous avez
raison d'insister parce que ça c'est un
vrai marqueur
quand les syndicats sont d'accords en
France et c'est rare on connaissez le
c'est que le problème il est très grave
pour ceux qui dirigent et donc oui on
est d'accord sur le fait de dire que
cette réforme elle est injuste
elle est et elle va frapper tout le
monde mais plus ce par exemple qu'on a
applaudi durant la covid donc nous notre
souci c'est de dire pas de pas
d'allongement de l'âge de la retraite
pas l'allongement de la durée du
cotisations et je et vous l'avez lu dans
notre communiqué on l'a c'est écrit noir
sur blanc c'est une première journée
donc il y en aura d'autres dans l'unité
syndicale de la mesure d'âge qui
pourrait vous inciter à reprendre le
travail aucune autre amélioration du
texte mais parce que c'est le fond c'est
le fond le gouvernement dit on va
pouvoir vous dire il y a pas que le
report de l'âge légal de départ donc oui
il y a pas que ça j'avais je l'ai lu il
y a pas que ça mais c'est c'est le gros
problème parce que toutes les mesures
qui vont avec dans ce qui sont dans ce
texte dépendent de l'allongement oui il
y a des gens qui vont continuer à partir
plutôt mais comme la ligne d'arrivée est
plus loin ils vont partir plus tard
qu'il ne pourrait partir aujourd'hui le
gouvernement dit on a de vraies marches
de manoeuvre encore aujourd'hui sur la
pénibilité et les carrières longues s'il
y avait de réelles améliorations sur ces
deux domaines-là est-ce que vous seriez
prêt à
reconsidérer le
concertations vous le savez personne n'a
fait la politique de la chaise vide
n'est-ce pas pourquoi alors que nous
avons expliqué des choses proposer des
choses rien n'a changé et c'est pas que
Martinez qu'il dit Laurent Berger dit la
même chose
deuxièmement quelle que soit
l'aménagement qu'on peut faire on va
partir plus tard donc c'est ça le
problème c'est ça le noeud du problème
mais évidemment on a fait les
propositions sur les carrières longues
qui vous l'avez constaté vont devoir
cotiser plus longtemps qu'avant 44 ans
pour eux c'est à dire que c'est ceux qui
ont commencé le plus tôt qui vont qui
vont cotiser le plus on a des
propositions sur l'employé seniors on a
fait des propositions sur l'amélioration
des pensions notamment pour les femmes
sauf qu'on est face à une réforme
dogmative dogmatique idéologique
d'ailleurs c'est Monsieur Macron qui
joue en gros sa carte personnelle
là-dessus et qui dit ça c'est pas
négociable sur l'emploi des seigneurs
justement Elisabeth borne est entendu
Stéphanie ce matin à la radio faire une
proposition qui serait par exemple dans
la prochaine loi travail qui va discuter
au printemps
d'interdire les plantes de départ
roulant dans les grands groupes est-ce
que ça vous paraît une bonne mesure nous
avons proposé
[Musique]
pas dit aujourd'hui dans la présentation
de la loi nous l'avons proposé et preuve
est-ce que si lundi dans le texte qui
est présent
ce point figure pour vous ça sera de
nature à revoir votre position pour
l'instant j'ai entendu qu'il y aurait un
index on dirait pas sympa ce que vous
faites nous on dit il faut des sanctions
parce que en plus de virer les plus
anciens des entreprises et les envoyer
au chômage ça se fait enfin en tout cas
moi j'ai demandé à la première ministre
avec quel argent pour l'instant je pense
que ça se fait avec de l'argent public
alors on peut toujours dire il faut dire
réduire les dépenses mais utiliser les
impôts pour virer du monde voilà mais
pour l'instant moi je ne peux commenter
que commenter ce que j'ai vu et pour
l'instant ce que d'ailleurs vous l'avez
vu comme moi c'est la conférence de
presse de la première ministre et j'ai
pas vu de sanction pour les entreprises
qui faisaient des plans de licenciement
pour les seniors et j'ai peut-être mal
lu mais du coup une question parce que
la gauche va sera aujourd'hui dans dans
les cortèges elle va défier pas à vos
côtés mais elle sera dans vos cortèges
la réforme Touraine présentée par les
socialistes elle allonge le nombre
d'annuités et elle fait qu'il faut 40
annuités est-ce que ce n'est pas aussi
43 années pardon est-ce que ce n'est pas
aussi la gauche qui est responsable du
fait que les Français devront partir
relisez ce que disait la CGT à l'époque
la CGT n'a pas soutenu
l'augmentation du nom du don de
trimestres nécessaires on n'a pas changé
d'avis on n'a pas changé d'avis voilà
quand la gauche d'ailleurs madame
Touraine
et soutient me semble-t-il président de
la République je l'ai vu danser au
Trocadéro quand monsieur Macron a été
élu au meeting de la nuque mardi soir il
y avait des très important non pas vous
mais il y avait des syndicalistes de la
CGT il y en a notamment un qui a demandé
la retraite à taux plat à 50 ans c'est
aussi ce que vous demandez nous nous
demandons la retraite à taux plein à 60
ans avec des mesures pour les carrières
longues pour les travaux pénibles qui
peuvent aller à 55 ans et à 50 ans si
vous prenez les éboueurs de Paris par
exemple ils ont une espérance de vie me
semble-t-il de 17 ans de moins moi j'ai
passé une demi-journée avec une
demi-journée eux ils y passent 30 ans
oui eux mériteraient des retraites
anticipées à 50 ans parce que c'est sont
des travaux très pénibles y compris dans
des conditions difficiles avec des
produits toxiques mais nous notre
proposition c'est revenir à la retraite
à 60 ans 55 ans pour des travaux
pénibles et pour certains travaux très
pénibles oui on peut aller jusqu'à 50
ans comment vous savez que la retraite à
60 ans ça coûte on parle de 80 milliards
c'est même plus que ça parce que nous on
l'a chiffré nous on est sérieux c'est ça
peut aller jusqu'à 100 milliards tout ce
qu'on propose on a financé par exemple
en laissant les seniors travailler
jusqu'à l'âge légal c'est 5 à 6
milliards l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des différences de pensions
pour les femmes mais si elles étaient
payées comme les hommes automatiquement
leur pension serait aussi au niveau des
hommes c'est de l'ordre de 6 milliards
une une comment dire au revoir les
exonérations de cotisations patronales
sur les plus bas salaires jusqu'à 1,6
fois le SMIC c'est des cotisations en
plus et puis avec des salaires augmentés
automatiquement il y a plus de
cotisations et puis je vais pas
développer parce que sinon on va passer
deux heures mais nous on a chiffré nos
propositions mais c'est des choix
politiques effectivement ou ce n'est pas
contrairement à cette réforme que le
travail qui finance que les salariés qui
financent la sécurité sociale parce que
dans notre pays le financement de la
sécurité sociale et le financement des
retraites est basé sur le travail et
dans le travail il y a ceux qui bossent
et puis les employeurs qui font bosser
les autres alors la suite projetons-nous
sur les journées de demain vous allez
vous réunir à nouveau en inter syndicale
ce soir pardon et donc vous allez
décider de la suite du mouvement
qu'est-ce que vous est-ce que vous avez
déjà une idée ce que vous allez faire
qu'est-ce que vous projetez une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation vous le saurez
ce soir d'accord vous vous souhaitez
vous l'avez dit vous souhaitez
c'est pas que Martinez c'est écrit dans
le texte aujourd'hui vous avez déjà une
nouvelle mais quelle forme parce que
recondition est-ce que ça sera une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation 8
je parle de l'intersyndicale donc
laissez la réunion se tenir et vous le
saurez ce soir on va déjà manifester
être en grève ça va être sympathique
vous allez voir et puis ce soir vous
aurez des nouvelles du reste vous disiez
vous êtes 8 puis vous êtes soutenu par
la nuque comment ça se passe aujourd'hui
entre vous Fabien Roussel a eu des
propos un peu un peu durs ce week-end
dans 10 ans que une partie de la nuque
se mettait pas forcément suffisamment
dans votre sillage et la critiquer cette
manifestation du 21
lancée par les organisations de jeunesse
quelle est l'ambiance aujourd'hui entre
vous
je me mêle pas des relations non mais
est-ce que vous trouvez que
je ne me mêle pas de leur relation je
crois que c'est déjà assez compliqué
comme ça
ce que on a des relations et
effectivement on a eu l'occasion de le
dire nous avons besoin de beaucoup de
soutien de relais à l'Assemblée
nationale il se trouve que il y a quand
même beaucoup de points de convergence
parce qu'ils ont lu nos propositions
mais on peut élargir
par exemple aujourd'hui la Confédération
paysanne appelle à manifester et il y
aura de nombreux agriculteurs dans les
manifestations et qu'après j'ai entendu
dans certains endroits il viendront avec
leur tracteur ça c'est le ça c'est me
semble-t-il l'image symbole mais il y a
beaucoup d'ONG association vous avez vu
que sans sans intellectuel et artiste
très célèbres se sont opposés c'est ça
la réalité mais juste pour terminer
Philippe Martinez quel mode d'action
vous espérez vous souhaitez vous pour la
suite du mouvement mais il faut il faut
et des
temps forts comme aujourd'hui parce que
nous l'avons déjà évoqué il y a beaucoup
de salariés avec des petits salaires qui
ne peuvent pas faire de grève continue
il y a des précaires qui sont menacés de
licenciement quand on fait grève et puis
partout c'est décidé avec les salariés
il faut je pense que le ton se durcisse
et qui est des grèves si possible
reconductibles
dans les racines riz avec plus d'essence
aussi
le blocage du pays donc je vais être
très précis il y a il va y avoir des
journées interprofessionnelles en tout
cas puisque c'est la première
aujourd'hui et puis dans des entreprises
aujourd'hui ça va discuter et puis ils
vont ils peuvent dire bah de morts pas
le boulot ou peut-être la semaine
prochaine on fera deux jours ou 3 jours
c'est ça mais c'est les salariés qui
décide c'est pas mal
on peut s'attendre dans les prochains
jours à des problèmes d'essence mais
c'est une question aussi mais oui non
mais bon concrètes pour les gens dans
les raffineries et ailleurs
on entendra pas plus on suivra ce soir
de la journée de mobilisation est-ce
qu'il va en être pour la suite du
mouvement merci Philippe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci
Christelle on passe au club des Titans
on continue à parler de cette réforme